miranda lambert and
l king took over the stage at the 2021
acms
and it was legendary it was just a
wonderful way to showcase
female talent on sunday the country
stars open the show with their hit
single
drunk and i don't want to go home they
set the tone for the evening with their
performance
and rocked coordinated leather jackets
with colorful
pink and teal fringe
[Music]
[Applause]
on friday miranda exclusively dished to
e.t on how she's celebrating the moment
with elle
who is currently expecting her first
child with beyonce
dan tooker yeah well i just have to
drink for two
so more for me i'm number one
glad they're having stuff yeah we're
glad to be back at work but this
project in particular is really i think
i mean it's a country music award show
and we get to sit up there in our
cowboy hats and play country music so i
think that's good to have part of that
in this show
and backstage at the show miranda posed
for photos with her husband brendan
mclaughlin
i also love a red carpet moment with you
and your hubby brendan
i mean so how is he getting acclimated
to
the glam the red carpets clearly there
haven't been as many this year but we
did see you guys
striking poses at the grammys and i'm
assuming the same's gonna be the case
this year
uh come sunday night well he loves it he
knows all about it yeah
he loves getting glam he's all glam he's
all he's all already picking out his
jacket
no way that's fun though he's great at
it how does he support you going into a
big performance like this
he's just chill about it all you know
what's fun is that he's not in the music
industry in any way and so he's just
happy to be there with me and let me do
my thing and then we kind of go home and
resume life that's so awesome number one
cheerleader right there
that's good stuff hot husband always
helps yes
drunk was released in february and
debuted at number one on the country
digital song
sales chart it was so fun i love l king
i'm a huge fan of hers we've recorded in
2019 so
it's that for a year but um i'm so glad
that like
just as everything's hopefully starting
to open up people are ready to have fun
such a good party in them
in february the singers both gushed to
e.t about working together
and showcasing girl power all of those
amazing wonderful ideas were all hers so
when
when like we got to do fooled around and
fell in love
it was just a wonderful way to showcase
female talent and you're such an amazing
person
to want to like just put that on the
forefront
and really showcase people that you
respect and you like working with
and to like really give power back to
women and i respect her to no end
[Music]
you